this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
tmj disorders are problems with your jaw
joint and chewing muscles
the temporal mandibular joint or tmj is
where your lower jaw meets your skull
you have two temporomandibular joints
one in front of each ear
each joint connects your lower jaw bone
called the mandible to the temporal
bones of your skull
a soft cushion called a disc sits
between the bones
the rounded ends of the mandible and the
discs slide forward when you open your
mouth
they slide back in place as you close
your mouth
muscles are attached to the mandible and
control its movement
the joint can open and close like a
hinge
but unlike many other joints the tmj can
also slide forward and backward
and side to side
because of this sliding ability the
joint needs your jaw muscles and teeth
to help guide it into proper position
when you open and close your mouth
in one type of tmj disorder your disc
may move out of place
in a second type your joint can be
damaged by medical problems like
arthritis where your joint becomes
inflamed and breaks down
and in a third type you may have painful
spasms in your jaw muscles
other health problems such as grinding
your teeth at night can also cause
symptoms in the joint
the most common symptom of tmj disorders
is pain in the joint and nearby muscles
sometimes pain in the tmj is mistaken
for an earache because the ear is so
close to the joint
headaches can result from pain that
starts in the muscles around your jaw
and temple area
other symptoms include
problems moving your jaw
painful clicking when you open or close
your mouth
and changes in the way your teeth meet
if you have questions about tmj
disorders speak with your doctor
you